the commission our vice president miss
eurovira thank you
maryam president honorable members thank
you very much for this important
discussion
thank you maram kanyetech once again
this is very important contribution to
maybe better understanding of where we
are and what we need to do
and thank you for establishing the inga
committee because already some time ago
we many of us felt that
too much maybe everything is at stake
and that we need to pay more attention
uh to
the phenomena of disinformation and and
trying to
decrease the trust of people in our
democracy
a lot has been said here about the
freedom of speech
let me assure you that the freedom of
speech remains the golden grail for us
it does not change it is in our european
dna that we protect the freedom of
speech
but
freedom of speech is not absolute
because by protecting absolute freedom
of speech
we will resign on the truth
and the society which resides on the
truth which
forgets to value the truth
is weak society and is lost and this is
what must not happen to us
said
that
we're seeing comparisons with
orwell and that we're
prohibiting
things from being said and that we're
introducing censorship as a result
to this let me say that we have to be
very clear about what we're talking
about
when we talk about
war propaganda disinformation
in the context of the war on ukraine
just this morning
i read
that in disinformation channels
you read that the
war on ukraine is just a fake it's a
hoax it's all lies and uh that people
actors are acting out the scenes well mr
do you think that you know a six scenes
of a six-year-old lose losing her life
are
scenes that are played by actors
or that an infant um
suffering a devastating fate in
mariopol uh
scenes acted out by
actors let's be clear what we're talking
about here all of us
let's be clear about the gruesome
um
events that are taking place when we
discuss this issue of disinformation in
the context of the war on ukraine and
this
the kind of things that are being spread
i think
it's clear that this is a
barbaric
act
these are barbaric acts that go with
that absolute power which is not limited
by checks and balances
leads to absolute evil
and
the action of the eu against russia
today and sputnik
i agree it's radical
reaction in extreme situation
it's radical it's unprecedented and it's
necessary
i want to say
to conclude one thing
what we see in the
days following the start of the invasion
of russia in ukraine after the
24th of february
we see that
the investments of putin's russia
in creating the sufficient power for
this infamous information in europe uh
went in vain
because it not it didn't disappear but
it is weakened now and we see that in
spite of the years
of massaging the public opinion in the
eu especially in the center and eastern
europe
the people show that they did not
believe it or they do not believe it now
and there is an extreme extremely big
and important wave of solidarity i want
to thank two people in poland in in
hungary in slovakia in romania
in my country for
such a strong
action helping the people
who are fleeing the war
and
this is now this is today but the
disinformation will gain again its power
i just imagine this is like the second
wave of tsunami
it will come and they are already
starting and they will be harvesting the
fear of people they will be fueling the
fear of people because there will be
increased crisis and are already
increased crisis of energy there will be
very probably increased crisis prices of
food there will be a big portion of
discomfort which the european people are
not used to
and we have to be ready for that we have
to strengthen all our actions against
this information everything we spoke
about today our action through the code
of practice and and many other things
but also we have to ourselves
tell the people the truth
because the the best
way of combating this information
is the truth
and i think that we will need mature
society well-informed people the people
who will trust us and the trust cannot
come without the truth thank you very
much
thank you vice president and for the
council brigitte clean clinker now has
the floor
madam president ladies and gentlemen
thank you very much
thank you for the quality of this debate
that we've pursued this morning the
european parliament 18 months ago by
setting up the injury committee was
quite right
this careful and well-documented
analysis that you've conducted has shown
the full extent and diversity of the
measures that our democracies have to
face
in order to justify
his military aggression against ukraine
the russian federation has launched
concerted and continuing
disinformation campaigns manipulating
information along the way trying to
target members of civil society in the
european union and in neighboring
countries by corrupting and manipulating
uh the facts
on the 2nd of march council adopted
restrictive measures
to rapidly suspend the activities of
broadcasting by hispanic and rt russia
today in the european union or targeted
at the european union these measures
will continue to be in place until the
aggression against ukraine is ceased and
until the russian federation and its
associated media stop conducting
disinformation and manipulation of
information missions against the
european union and its member states
the presidency supports the efforts
undertaken by the european external
action service and the european
commission attempting to unmask the
manipulations uh the manipulation of
information the media or infamous
websites
providing biased information about the
conflict uh the course of it and the
role of the european union and of
europeans
it is further more important that the
major platforms that are online play
their role to try and uncover and reduce
the manipulation of information in the
context of this conflict
generally speaking council is playing an
active role in this by
examining the european commission's
initiatives
such as the action plan for european
democracy
legislation on digital services
and the sri
d2 directive and by coming up with more
complete and ambitious
attempts to strengthen the resilience of
our society and fight against
disinformation attacks and
hybrid threats
work is underway in council right now to
put together a european union provision
to provide a coordinated response to the
hybrid
manipulation of information campaign
targeting the european union and its
member states
allow me once again to congratulate you
on this
extensive work that has been conducted
over the last year and a half and allow
me to reassure you once again
that the presidency and the council of
minister as a whole
attach great importance to the
protection of our democratic processes
institutions and society against any
interference including information
interference the council will continue
to support common efforts to go forward
in this respect by bringing together
european responses
uh which are both ambitious and
determined the european summit that will
be held at the end of uh next week in in
versailles will turn its attention
precisely to that our heads of state and
government in the context that we're
familiar with will be taking this
subject extremely seriously
protecting our democratic processes that
we are so attached to and i think the
debate this morning has clearly shown
that
requires us to focus all of our efforts
in a structured and joint manner thank
you very much
thank you now
a very timely and important debate is
now close thank you and congratulations
to the reporter the vote on the
amendments will be held today and the
final vote tomorrow the sitting is
expanding till the next item thank you
foreign
good afternoon dear
colleagues
dear oksana zabusco
i am very pleased to welcome you at this
year's celebration of international
women's day
and on this day
the word
celebration
is not i think a word we could use
because the shelling on
ukraine continues unabated
we have all seen
heard and felt
some of the misery of the victims of the
aggression
the first of which are always
women and girls
and yet in these dark days we wish we
witnessed strengths
and we witness courage
in ukraine women are resisting
they are standing up
pushing back
and taking up arms against their
aggressor
so it is therefore even more important
and the privilege to have with us today
a ukrainian woman and writer
oxana zabusco
whose literature
and strong voice
exhibits the very strength
of ukrainian women in the face of
oppression oksana you left ukraine two
weeks ago with nothing but your hand
luggage and you have not had the
possibility to return
since
in russia and in belarus women are
protesting on the streets
in an act of defiance against their
governments
and they do this
in spite of the serious repercussions
that they face
to these women
we say
europe stands united with you
we stand united with you
because there are no winners in war
there is only death
only the pain that someone bears when
they are forced to leave their country
when they learn that their loved ones
are not coming home
when they have to bury
their children
colleagues the brave and resilient women
of ukraine
serve as an inspiration to us all
because yes there is extraordinary power
behind a ukrainian woman asking a fully
armed russian soldier to put sunflower
seeds in his pocket so that if he dies
on her homeland flowers may bloom from
his lifeless body
these are the acts of heroines
defending the same european values that
we hold and on international women's day
this european parliament will serve as a
platform for the strength of these brave
women to be shown to the world thank you
and oksana you have the floor
[Applause]
dear members
dear friends
i cannot be more appreciative
for this invitation
and for this unique opportunity to speak
here
on women's rights day
at probably the darkest hour in europe
since 1913
for most of my literary career i've been
speaking for women and in the name of
women
in my writings i've been aimed to give
voice to the experiences of women
subjected to violence
to those believing and dead whose
feelings ideas or accomplishments were
ignored devalued or simply forgotten
i've spoken for women's rights to be
free from discrimination and gender
inequality for their right to live in
accordance with their own wishes and
preferences
this however
is
the first time
that i have to stand up
for a woman's
right
to life itself
ukrainians are a strong
this appears to have surprised many in
the west
yet were it not so we would not have
survived stalin's genocide the horrific
man-made famine of 1933
notably still unrecognized by most of
the countries represented here
and we are a nation of strong women too
along with the rest of the world
i cannot but admire with tears in my
eyes
my fellow country women now fighting
right alongside our men
they have joined the army and the civil
territorial defense forces
they manage the distribution of supplies
across our besieged cities
some of which like marijuana stand on
the verge of a humanitarian catastrophe
now
they give birth in bomb shelters
supported and supervised by doctors
online
ukrainian doctors meanwhile have created
facebook pages offering instructions on
how women over 37 weeks pregnant might
safely deliver children in bomb shelters
an image
that strikes me as almost biblical as
sounds of mary's hide with their
newborns evading king carrot in
basements subway stations and other
stables
yes
we are strong
and grateful
for your support
and your admiration
the problem is putin's bombs
will not be stopped
by the strengths of our spirit
and babies born
in bomb shelters die of sepsis caused
with the dust raining down on them
during attacks
mary's stable was much more hygienic
since february 24th
when russia launched its invasion
conceived as a blitzkrieg only to be
foiled by the ferocious determination of
our military and mobilized civilians
one of history's unshakable rules has
been reconfirmed
in any hot
war
women make
the most vulnerable targets
if only because it's women who remain to
take care of those in need
of children and the elderly
and it is precisely this
living shield
which vladimir putin
now uses to break ukraine's heroic
resistance
having failed to take cave
putin began
shelling residential areas
including elementary schools nurseries
and hospitals
let me take the liberty of stressing
this
every
moment of hesitation
on the side of western policy makers
and nato decision makers
about whether to provide ukraine with
anti-aircraft weapons
not to speak of the no-fly zone
every coffee break you are taking during
your discussions about how to interfere
without provoking putin to go further
costs
someone's life
most likely a civilian
a woman's or a child's
after all putin said it quite openly
back on april 17 2014
in the first
act
of the current tragedy
which he called a special military
operation russian spring
and which then resulted in the
annexation of crimea and in creating two
russian-controlled military zones in
donbass but was initially meant to
accomplish much more
that day
eight years ago he openly announced
that russian troops in donbass
would be standing against ukrainian army
behind
ukrainian women and children
i quote literally not in front of them
but behind
behind
daring ukrainian army
to shoot
a living shield a typical terrorist
tactic
he was then so confident
of his superiority
so sure that no one would dare stop him
that he did not even bother to lie out
of contempt to his audience
isn't it amazing ladies and gentlemen
that no one
outside of ukraine maybe took them his
words seriously
in may 2014 after russian soldiers in
donbass had already begun slicing open
people's bellies and shooting at
teenagers for carrying yellow and blue
flags
i was speaking in berlin at the european
writers forum
and when in my speech i compared putin
to hitler and stalin the moderator was
so shocked that my microphone was turned
off and in the publication the
comparison was censored
eight years passed
so many human lives could have been
saved
if only the eu and the u.s
would have woken up
eight years ago to the fact that they
knew hitler
was ready to pick up where the previous
one had left off
if the current package of sanctions had
been applied to russia
yes
sound similar to the litanies
that writers and intellectuals who
survived
world war ii
were proposing after the war ended
yet for me it is also a sign that we
and by we i mean all western
civilization to which ukraine with its
millennium long history also belongs
but we have not learned too much from
history
putin deliberately imitates hitler he
even uses hitler's very language
referring to the final solution of the
ukrainian question
and barely disguising quotations from
hitler's speech at reichstag on
september 1st 1939
i will not war against women and
children
i have ordered my air force to restrict
itself to attacks on military objectives
that's from 1939
not from 2022
yes ladies and gentlemen
it is
the announcement of war
vladimir putin has done it in his
tricky
perverted kgb language
but i am here to tell you as a writer
who does know something about language
and how easily its power can be misused
that it is already a world war
not a
conflict in ukraine as it is still
described in many western media
and that you better trust
mr putin when he pronounces his
ambitions
he has already claimed back the former
soviet bloc which is what he really
means by demanding that nato pull back
from eastern europe and he won't stop
unless
he is stopped by an international front
of all those nations who still believe
that freedom
and human solidarity
are worse more
than gas and oil
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
you have all seen videos
of how ukrainian civilians men and women
stop russian tanks with bare hands and
loud curses
here lies the secret of our heroism
we are not
afraid of russia
of all the nations in europe we know
that what putin has for decades been
selling to the west
as the true story
his nuclear blackmailing included
is nothing but a pack of lies
illusion and bluff
we know this because we do have our
share
in the past
300 years of russian imperial greatness
and by no means a minor one
that is why of all the nations that is
ukraine that has found herself at the
forefront of this war without us
there can be no russian empire
no
evil empire ladies and gentlemen that
used to be a good term after all
first
there was austria then czechoslovakia
then poland then europe
first it was georgia then belarus then
ukraine
afterwards
europe
while i was writing this
my niece
and her two children
one eight years old the other eight
months old
we're driving from cave to western
ukraine
at a speed
200 kilometers in 10 hours
women of ukraine are fleeing and mass
from the russian bombs flattening their
homes
while ukrainian men stay to fight as
long as it's needed to free europe
from the specter of the new
totalitarianism
they all know their job
both men and women
please
don't
be afraid
to protect the sky above them
thank you
thank you
thank you so much your roxanna for those
heartfelt words we will now
hear from the representatives of the
political groups starting with the epp
group francis fitzgerald
thank you oksana for that powerful
speech and thank you roberta for
ensuring that we had oxana here with us
today
it was truly chilling to hear your words
of women giving birth
in underground stations with doctors
online and babies getting sepsis and all
of your other images too
we have spent much of the past 13 days
talking about european values
because as
you have said oksana
as ukrainians take to the front line to
defend their country
they are not just defending themselves
and their own beliefs
but the core of our very union here
human rights
democracy the rule of law
these are our european values
and right at the very heart is gender
equality
not an add-on
not an extra
but in fact essential
and quintessentially european from the
start of our project
yet the tragedy of this international
women's day
is that thousands of women as you have
said oksana are running under a hail of
bullets
avoiding missiles and their houses
falling down around them
running away from the violence
protecting their children and equally
running into the fire to protect our
european values
just two short weeks ago these were the
women contributing to ukraine
in business in communities and in
building up the country's democratic
spirit
and democracy
now they run under sniper fire
yet ukrainian women have others who know
what it is like
even in the past year
asked the women of afghanistan denied
their voice their education their lives
once again
and the women in ethiopia raped and
brutalized is it just another weapon of
war the women of yemen the women of
belarus
this is just one year for women in some
of the worst places to be a woman
now imagine all the rest
even in the best of places to be a woman
we have unfinished democracies
unfinished gender equality agendas
in each of these places and with each of
these experiences
the task of finding peaceful solutions
must be at the top of our agenda
the un the us g7 nato if we are to have
a sustainable and meaningful peace we
cannot only have the women working from
the ground up
we must have women
in the senior decision-making force of
our world
human rights
democracy the rule of law
our european values are worth fighting
for
and gender equality is right at the
heart
thank you
thank you very much miss fitzgerald and
now on behalf of the snd group iracia
garcia perez
gracias
thank you president
and thank you very much
oksana
for
speaking for millions of women
who are being attacked
in terms of their fundamental principles
refugee women fleeing ukraine with their
sons and daughters ukrainian women
staying in ukraine
having to look after the most vulnerable
because it's always us
women
who are the most vulnerable in these
situations and hearing oxana's voice
today in the house of european democracy
is so important this 8th of may is
important it is different
but please allow me
to
make reference to the feminist movement
in europe and the world feminism does
not deal in borders we have a common
fight for our rights and freedoms and
that is why i'd like to stress
the
bravery of women in ukraine and
afghanistan and in so many places in the
world where raising your voice
means you
risk your life
we're standing with all the women who
suffer
and who are raising their voices for a
fairer and more equal world where we
have the same rights
this day the 8th of may is important
and
we european women cannot cross our arms
or resign ourselves
there are many of us that we have to be
able to move forward in this world
in this society long live the feminist
struggle long live the 8th of march
thank you very much
ms garcia perez i give the floor next on
behalf of the renew group to stefan
sessions
madam president two colleagues
and madame zabusco
this
international day of women's rights is
taking place against a very gloomy
backdrop the images coming from ukraine
tell us about two facts that we know
about women's struggles women suffer
specific structural forms of violence
structural
use
of rape as a
war crime
having been reported just a few days ago
women also are in the front line in
times of crisis hospitals schools
so many women stay
in their posts and go into war
go to the front
and this
shows us just how important we must
it is to support the struggle for
equality between men and women and our
group
defends these values without any
reservation in this house and beyond but
i think we can go further when it comes
to
equality between men and women it must
be part of the european union's
political identity just as peace is a
european value so when you say one you
are pro-european that can mean that you
are a feminist and that you accept
that
as part of europe's dna
simon vale consistently asked for member
states to put into place
advanced progressive measures of for the
right to abortion and contraception uh
banning violence against women freedom
to participate in professional and
political activities um
now in 2022 we're
looking two member states to implement
new protections
for
women and so
madame zabusco we very much hope that we
will be able to welcome you your people
uh into a europe that is even more
progressive and more feminist than it is
today thank you
much uh
next on behalf of the green group ska
keller
thank you dear colleagues
yes we have made
advances for gender equality
the pure fact that i stand here today
as a female politician as the president
of my group
the fact that we have a female president
of the parliament
that is unfortunately nothing to be
taken for granted
it is the result of the incredible work
of the many women before us who fought
for equal rights for gender equality
and with that in mind today becomes more
than a celebration of women's rights
it becomes a reminder of the hard work
that we need to put in for women's
rights a reminder of how much equality
we're still missing
and in times of war
women are one of the most vulnerable
groups threatened by gender-based
violence fleeing conflict zones under
horrible conditions and at high risk of
human trafficking trafficking while
often being excluded from the formal
negotiations
to end the conflicts that they are
suffering from
the idea of feminism is about creating a
fair world a world in which we can live
freely equally and in peace
in the last two weeks we have seen these
ideals demonstrated by the brave women
of ukraine doing everything in their
power to keep their families and their
communities safe
and i also want to stress that we see
all the efforts of women in russia in
belarus
protesting to show they disagree with
this war
with this horrific war of putin who's
waging it against ukraine
all the while by not forgetting the
efforts and the suffering of women in
syria afghanistan
yemen and so many other conflicts in the
world
these women
show us what courage and what resilience
looks like and this is the courage that
we lose when women are not involved in
the decision-making processes
experience shows that when women are
part of the decision-making in
peacemaking efforts the resulting piece
is longer lasting and more broadly
carried by society because diverse
perspectives and additional knowledge is
included
it is our joint responsibility to make
sure that women around the world receive
equal opportunities to get their feet
into the door and take their rightful
place at the table
feminism is the key to a more equal and
more peaceful world not just for women
but for all of us and for the
generations to come thank you
thank you miss keller and now on behalf
of the id group simona baldassare
thank you president
colleagues
we are thinking of the women in ukraine
suffering from war refugee women who've
managed to flee
with their children those exposed to
rape and violence as
unicef has so
reported they are strong women fighting
for peace maria one of the ukrainian
women who saw her
city destroyed and young and
old people killed
and members of parliament taking up arms
or mia the first child born
and
bombardment of
kiev
the first italian woman to go to the
front as a reporter
said
there's nothing
like
an unjust war for destroying people's
dignity
so let us remember those who are under
the yoke of the taliban as well and the
situation in europe is worrying as well
the latest euro barometer survey in
europe shows a harsh reality three out
of four women
in the eu eight out of ten
in italy have experienced greater
violence in the last two years
difficulties
reconciling work and family life having
to choose between the two women who are
more worried but still show courage and
tenacity
and
we see those working against
trafficking
and then there's the issue of surrogacy
too many victims of that in the world so
we really need to
encourage women and give them hope
as john paul ii said
thank you women for being
a woman through your femininity
femininity you help us understand the
world better and contribute to human
relations thank you
next on behalf of the ecr group
asitakanko
thank you madam president
has anyone
recently
looked into their mother's eyes
when i look
into my mother's eyes
i see the scars and our failure to
protect women
when i look in my daughter's eyes
i see the promise
we must keep for the future
as lawmakers
as lawmakers
we do have the power to change things to
build a world where all women are free
dear colleagues i'm honored to stand to
be standing here today on international
women's day
but i wish
this day was no longer necessary
as i stand here i think of the women we
know and those we do not know
i think of us and the power we have to
drive change
we must consolidate the rights that we
have acquired and wield more
because equality is unfinished business
because freedom is in danger
the ukrainian women who husily had to
kiss their husbands goodbye and walk
away alone and torn apart know this
this war is a shame
and a failure for the west
they have so much courage
when i listened to you today
i didn't know what to say anymore to be
honest i could have walked here and just
gave you a hug
because sometimes words are not enough
but this would not be appropriate and
would also not help you for anything
today so what i want to say is know
that we see and hear you
thank you for coming and speaking to us
your courage
and your authenticity remind us
of what we are fighting for
we must we must fight for people like
you but we must also fight for every
other women
women of today and women of tomorrow
destroyed by war against their country
or by war against the person
this year several women were killed also
in europe
everywhere women have to fight to
survive
in february madeleine 44 years old was
trying to escape her ex-partner in
belgium who was strangling her
eventually he killed her son who was
trying to protect her
this is not a single story
but together we are stronger
thank you
thank you very much
asita next on behalf of the left group
mano aubry
never forget
that a crisis be it political economic
or religious will challenge women
the rights are never established forever
you have to be vigilant throughout your
life seem under above why use those
words to warn us that the walk to
equality between men and women is beset
by troubles and it's a combat that must
be undertaken at any moment particularly
in a time of war
in ukraine right now and i would welc i
would salute the courage of all of those
women women have signed up to the night
patrols in the resistance sleeping in
the metro that being the only place they
are safe and also all of those women who
have
stood behind their society
women who have been victims of violence
and rapist weapons of war
when zubiker know that all of the women
of europe
are standing at your side and are
prepared to fight this battle this
battle for peace and the battle
to be able to decide over our own bodies
and
this battle
imposed by
brutality and fear is one that always
challenges
women
they've been subjected in our own
countries to many challenges in recent
years it's
throughout the pandemic it's been women
the nurses who have been
mobilized in the front line and they
have
suffered
women
who
had saw a massive rise in domestic
violence uh women whose rights
were sacrificed because of the huge
difficulty
these uh
some some of the women have been
declared illegal in some european
countries and simone de beauvoir was
right these are not rights that ever
established any pretext is sufficient in
order to put women in the second line
and to
push back against their rights so
we've seen in hungary and poland and
even in my country france there's a rise
of hatred against women there's always
going to be these attacks on women and
it is essential therefore that
we must stop people who
sign up to those views getting into
power and it's important that women
should be able to live in peace
maintaining their and upholding their
dignity
in peace
at work at home in the street
and i would like to finish
with these words
the time to be angry is now
we
must uh all believe in this and and uh
to the extent of which we are millions
in the battle members laura ferrara
thank you president and thank you to
oksana sabutsko for her
words for bearing witness
all we can do today is think about women
of all ages experiencing armed conflict
who are displaced
who are in a very difficult situation
with facing
turbulence of all thoughts which
threaten
our what we've achieved in social and
economic terms compressing the space
for
social
being
we see the impact of the pandemic a
disproportionate impact on women
affecting the part their participation
in the labor market increasing
unemployment
insecurity increasing the wage gap
and penalizing women because of their
greater family and care responsibilities
and gender violence in all forms online
offline this is still a tragedy
affecting women's exercise of their
rights and their mental and physical
health
prevention of this prosecuting it
and mechanisms for supporting victims
all this requires resources and effort
and
we see that there's been some regression
in terms of abortion rights
the ability to decide
one's own
sexuality and sexual and reproductive
health for oneself without abuse and
then gender legislation in the eu and
parliamentary activities
this is another
piece in the puzzle
which would allow women to enjoy equal
opportunities and live their own lives
every year we think about these issues
and we renew our commitment
to remove structural and cultural
impediments
to
participation and decision making
and
we're talking about promoting equality
which isn't just a fundamental of value
of the eu it's
a human
fundamental guaranteeing peace and
security thank you
[Applause]
that concludes this special session
thank you once again to oxana and to all
the colleagues who engaged in this very
important
debate i will now move to today's voting
session the voting session will be open
from 12 30 until 1 45 and the results
will then be announced at seven o'clock
this evening uh the debates will resume
at three o'clock this afternoon with the
council and commissioned statements on
the deterioration of the situation of
refugees as a consequence of the russian
aggression against ukraine have a good
afternoon
you
yes
you